This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Hey, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast, Here's the Thing. I talk to composer Mark Shaman. It's about the hang. It's the pleasure of hanging out with the people that you're with. You know, Rob and I was always a great hang.
And director Morgan Neville. Film School teaches you all the wrong things about making documentary. What do you want to say? Documentary is all about your ear. What do you hear? I feel like my job is listening really, really hard. Listen to Here's the Thing on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
It just came out. Jeremy, what did you just do? You just sit yourself up for failure. I've never heard you tell this story. I've never told this story. This must have been tucked deep, deep in the Jeremy Lynn file. My name is MC Jen. I'm excited to tell you about laugh but not least.
I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times. These will be conversations that remind us all. Life is hard. laugh harder. Listen and laugh but not least with MC Jen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Happy pride from the Outspoken Podcast Network. All month long and all year round, we're celebrating being loud, proud, and always original. It's me, Brandon Kyle Goodman, host of the podcast, Tell Me Something Messy. Check out my show for unfiltered takes on dating, relationships, and adulting.
Listen to High Key for the best pop culture takes, and there are no girls on the internet for all your tech news. favorite celebrity Kikis, check out outlaws with T.S. Madison. Learn to love yourself unapologetically with BFF, Black Fat Fem, and start your day with intention with waking up with Ryan coming in July. Celebrate Pride with the Outspoken Network. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Pride and Listen Now. This Black Music Month, the Questlove show celebrates the visionaries, shaping culture, Drusown, from country trailblazer Mickey Gaidon to hip-hop icon Fat 5 Freddie, The sonic genius of Thundercat and the revolutionary voice of Chuck D. I want it loud.
So the timing might be off, the sound might be muffled, but what's going to come out of there is something that you can feel. Celebrate Black Music Month with special episodes of the Questlove show. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemis Speg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes. moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. It is so great to have you here back for another episode of the psychology of your 20s back for another bonus episode. I'm kind of doing it old school. I'm like bringing it
back to the early days, the like early 2021, 2021, 22 days of the podcast where I would get on the mic and just talk about random stuff, random things in my bedroom. I was going to do like a bonus episode today on Freud and on false memories and all this stuff. And I was like, I just don't really feel like it. I actually just feel like chatting. And so I'm going to do it. I was like, oh, wait, this is actually my podcast. I can just chat. I can just talk to you guys about my life and what I've been up to and my 20s rather than like the psychology behind it. And I thought what would be like a good kind of topic, kind of structured to this episode, so I don't just go off on tangents, is a little bit of like a London update and a
little bit of an update around how my life is in London since moving here at the start of the year and things that I've been learning, things that I've been realizing, particularly this like one reoccurring theme that I am spotting in my life, which is kind of a failure or an inability to be in the season of life that I am currently in. And being in London has, because it has been such, like one of the biggest shocks to my system and I guess to my life, has put this in clearer perspectives than any other situation has. Like, it's become so evident to me that this is a problem for me, that I cannot just like sit in the chapter of life that I am in.
I am constantly thinking ahead, constantly thinking of something. better, constantly getting to the place I want to be and then being like, okay, so what's next? And this is the thing, oh my God, I'm really just jumping straight into it. But this is what I've realized with London. I spent two years, two years imagining my life here, two years, I guess preparing. And if you guys know the story, basically I have to wait for my boyfriend Tom to finish an accreditation for his job so that we could move here. And being very patient and being like, when I get to London, like my real adult life is going to start and my 20s are going to really start and this big adventure is going to occur and I'm going to be so happy and I'm
going to be so fulfilled and my career is going to be great. I'm going to be a city gal. And I've been here now for eight months and the only thing I want is to move home. And all I can think about is like, oh my God, how good is it going to be when we go back to Australia? How good is it going to be when we go back to Australia and we're going to buy a big piece of land like in Queensland and we get to build our home and I really want to build like a big community space with like art like rooms for like artist retreats and like for community meals and I want to build like a like a small rescue facility we can get sheltered dogs like blah blah blah blah and I'm like wait what what has just happened here because
again I just explained it. spent all this time wanting this future, wanting this reality, which it is now. It's my reality, the moment that I am in, and I'm here. And it hasn't been terrible. It's actually been quite great. And suddenly I'm like, okay, what's next? What's next? And this inability to sit and be happy with the moment, with the season, with the chapter that I currently inhabit is, I'm kind of recognizing a little bit of a problem. So I've basically just given you everything. we're going to talk about right off the bat. But there's a bit more complexity to it. I kind of want to discuss. I have gotten a lot of questions I should say from people who are like,
hey, how is London? I'm about to move. I'm thinking of moving. I'm thinking of moving not to London, but in general, what's been your experience? So I thought I'd go through that and then talk about one I'm planning to leave, I guess. And this more general pathological, um, kind of inability to be, I was going to say inability to be happy. Inability to be happy. Inability to be happy, no, inability to be at ease with my life. So we have been in London now for, we moved in December, so it's, what is it, June, so six months, seven months at this point. I would say we moved at a terrible time. And I can see that in hindsight that we did not plan our move well. Firstly, we moved right as the podcast was like going on Netflix. And I spoke about this in a
previous episode. That was just the most stressful period of my life. Something you may not know about that. I feel like it's this huge crazy thing. You know, the psychology of your 20s on Netflix. It's a massive like career achievement. I genuinely couldn't have dreamed it. It was so stressful because I signed that contract literally four hours before I got on the plane. I really didn't think it was going to happen. And then I got here. We went on holiday with my week. Firstly, I got to London. and we didn't have anywhere to live because the place we were meant to be staying had fallen through. So we had like 10 days or less. I can't remember the timelines to find somewhere to live.
And then we went on holiday with my family. And then in the middle of that holiday, I get literally on New Year's Day, New Year's Eve, I get this email from the team being like, hey, we need to get the Netflix episodes going. And I was like, I have literally just moved country. I don't have a studio, I don't have a clue, I don't have anybody really to help me. So the first half of the year was very stressful. I think if we had known that was going to happen, we probably would have held off. The other thing that if you've moved to London or thinking of it that you'll hear come up a lot is do you move in summer or do you move in winter?
The thing with moving in winter is that you are basically guaranteeing that the first three to four months is going to be miserable and rotten, but then you get the reward of summer, right? And when you go into summer, by that stage, you probably have a few friends. You probably have a bit more of a community. You have a bit more of a foundation so you can really enjoy the summer. And then the comparative kind of option is that you move in the summer. It's great because you move in. It's just the city comes alive. But then you kind of are, the lull comes during the winter.
We did the first one. It was pretty miserable. I've done an episode before on seasonal depression. and when I lived in Canberra, I definitely had a bite of that apple. Like, I definitely had experienced it. Well, I thought I had. No. No, no, no, no.
It was, I had no words to describe the deep sadness. The deep sadness. I was like, oh my gosh. No wonder such sad literature comes from cold. climates. Like, you guys have ice and chill in your bones, like sadness. And that's what it felt like. And so we really struggled with that. And then also my boyfriend Tom was just looking for a job. And that's like the next thing I'll talk about in terms of just like advice for people who want to move here. The job market just from seeing people navigating it is so tricky. And I remember hearing stories.
Like with Australia and the UK, there is a long, obviously, we're a Commonwealth country. So we have this like basically we are quote unquote owned by the UK. And what that's kind of meant is that through many generations, like Australians will go, like every generation kind of goes to the UK. Like there is this kind of tidal wave around like the ages of 23 to 28 where like, you know, 25% of Australians will probably move to London or will move to the UK. And most people that I know have a friend or I know people. people who have done it and our parents generation have done it like it's a very like a cultural thing
and I remember talking to my parents and then also you know friends parents as well you know aunts and uncles and everybody then being like oh my god moving to the UK is an amazing opportunity you go you make more money it's you just the opportunities are everywhere and it feels like that is a very outdated narrative and of course we did know that we understand stand the state of the world, but you really can't overstay how different it was from like the glory days of like my parents' generation and their friends' generation of like, move to London and you get, you get this job and like, you make all this money because there's all this capital. And it's like, no, no, no, no, no. The reality is so different. And again, I will say, like,
we knew that. We were, we weren't naive coming into it. But very few things prepare you for how much money you will spend, how quickly you will chew through your savings, and how difficult it will be to find a job, I think, in most industries. And I say that because Tom's a lawyer, he struggled in that space. But every other friend that I have people who work in design, people who work in even retail, people who work in museums, people who work in consulting, people who work in, like, all these different industries have all said, like, it is a struggle. Like if you get a job offer in the first three months, you have done exceptionally well. So I was going to go into like the best and worst things of our experience in London so far.
I would say that period of me and Tom's kind of like journey here was very, very difficult. Finding an apartment not so difficult. I thought that was going to be really hard. We moved at a time when they said it's like one of the best times to find places it was in December. Definitely didn't feel that way because we were scrambling. but we have such a beautiful place. It is my dream apartment in a way that's like, it's my dream apartment for my 20s, right? There's definitely things like we're on the top floor, like the fourth floor of this terrace house and there's no elevator.
And right now as I'm recording this, it is a massive heat wave and there is no aircon and all the heat rises. And I cannot express to you how hot it is here. A lot of people have been asking me, you know, it's a heat wave in London. Like, surely you're used to this. you're Australian, you're like, you spent your summers in Queensland and like, no, it's, it's no, it's so different. It's, the, the structures and the facilities and like the infrastructure, I should say, is not built for this heat. And definitely, we've been feeling that. But what was I talking about? Yes, our apartment is gorgeous. It has this, like, um, mezzanine. It's like a loft apartment.
So, like, the bottom floor is, like, where our bedroom is and our lounge room and our bathroom and then the top floor is like a second bedroom slash living room that has a view of the entirety of London and we didn't even realize until we moved in like the whole London skyline you can see from our top floor window and it's like one of my favorite things is to be like oh my god yeah come over and see our see our view so that's a that's a pro job job hunting con making friends has been relatively easy I know I said in my episode when I was like I'm moving to London, just so you guys know, I was like, I'm most worried about this. This is, and I'm speaking from personal experience, so if this wasn't your experience, again, it's, don't think that you've done
anything wrong, but this has been the easiest city for me to make friends in. And maybe it was the attitude that I came in with, which was like, I need to make friends. And I'm, it's going to be a mission. This is as important as finding an apartment, as important as finding a job for like, for Tom and, you know, and for establishing our careers here. And we just kind of went home. And we were just so rewarded with just incredible friendships and not just Australians. We also were friends with people who are born and bright in the UK,
which I think is like a stereotype of like Aussies and Kiwis move over here and then all their friends are just, or Americans or whoever, move over here and they just remain in their interior circles. But no, we have this amazing community. That has been a huge pro. A con going back and forth. has been, I think, the impact on my emotional state, though. So this is kind of a good segue into why I want to go home now.
I'm done. I'm ready to leave. I've done it. Which I'm not at that level yet, but London has definitely made me angrier. It has made me more irritable. It has made me a less forgiving person. And that is in every kind of area of my life. You know, it's very, I come home and navigating the tube system and navigating public transport
and navigating crowds and all that means that I get home and I'm like, I'm cranky. Somebody like, your steps in front of me, I'm like, I'm cranky. Oh my God. Can I say what my biggest issue with London is? Choose the side of the path. Oh, my God. I can't believe I haven't mentioned this at some point. In Australia, and obviously, sorry, I know I keep like being like, in Australia, in Australia, in Australia.
But in Australia, like, and in most countries, it's like you walk on the right or you walk on the left. They're what? They don't seem to compute that that makes things more efficient. And so that has been like a real adjustment. I think that and also the heat recently and just how many people are in the city, how difficult it is to navigate when you live in central London means that your cognitive load is just significant. And I guess my final con, which is one that's a bit more serious, has been, In my adjustment to this new country and new system is the healthcare system.
And I have really struggled to navigate it. And I've really struggled to just get answers for things. I took a turn there, but you guys know at the start of last year, I had this really insane health scare where I went in for a retinal scan. and my optic nerve was swollen and the doctors were essentially like there are three options. There's the really, really bad option, which is a tumour. There is the still bad but medium option, which is MS or there's this other option which is, like you have too much fluid in your brain.
And it was this real waiting game of like, well, I fucking hope it's not the first two options and luckily it wasn't, thank God. now I have this condition that I need to manage. And that means that wherever I live, every three to six months, I have to go and see an ophthalmologist and a neurologist to make sure that everything is working as it should be, right? And that my vision is still okay, that other symptoms are being managed,
because when you have too much fluid in your brain, it's not pleasant. You, duh. Firstly, you can go blind. secondly you get these crazy like headaches that I can't even explain it's like somebody's squeezing you like a pimple and you get this like wishing in your ear that's really irritating so essentially I got here and I was like okay priority number one is I need to get a specialist for this condition that I have I'm still on the wait list I'm still on a wait list and I have found that
understandable because there's a lot of other people who needs to be seen and obviously like it's not like I should come in and get top priority. Not at all, but I just mean, I got on the wait list in February and it's now June and that is just shocking to me, considering the standard of care and like the level of care that I am used to, which is that you'll seem pretty quickly. And maybe it's just my experience because when I was first diagnosed, it was such a, quote, unquote, emergency because they weren't, they didn't have any answers. But I really struggle with that. And then I'm having some other health problems to do with my stomach. And I was, like, crying in my GP's office the other day, just being like, can you help me?
Like, how I just, and just being like, I don't even know what question to ask you, but can you help me? And she's like, well, I've made the referral. And it's just kind of like, okay, so either you go private and you spend so much money, or you just kind of have to sit and wait. And then, not to give you guys too many private details, but my symptoms were getting worse in a way that's like not unsurious. Like it and I qualified. I was put into like the two week wait list process. So basically if your symptoms get worse, like and you're under the age of 40, they are like, well, we need to see you quickly. And I went back in and I was like, hey, like I did this, you know, we did this test again. And the test is shown that things are getting worse. Can you like now I meet the thing. And she's like, okay, yeah, yeah, I'll put you on the wait list. And. I haven't heard anything. And so there's been a lot of stress and anxiety around what is going on in my body. How do I access healthcare here? Is it worth paying the money? And just not really
knowing how to do it. And this isn't to say like the NHS isn't a great system, right? This isn't to say that public healthcare isn't a genuine miracle. It's just that compared to what I'm used to, finding the difference really scary because I'm expecting answers or I'm expecting a way of communicating that is different to like what I'm experiencing. Like for example, I got this appointment and it was like, okay, this is, that your appointment is at 5 a.m. on like the 3rd of July. And it was weird because I was like, but nobody asked me if I'm available then and I'm not. Nobody like called me and I'm so used to being like, okay, well, I choose my appointment time because why give somebody an appointment time they can't go to if they're just going to have to cancel.
And that just, it's not how it's done here. So that's been quite stressful. And I guess this kind of leads me into why I want to go home. You know, we've done eight months in the UK. And we said at six months time, we would decide whether we wanted to do two years. And the big reason we decided that we've, we kind of had a point where we would decide if we really wanted to stay for a while is also because of our dog. Don't worry, Talu is still very much. much okay she's very loved she is very happy probably the happiest dog in the world she's with my
parents and my sisters and honestly i know she's happy i miss her a lot and it is a daily conversation of like oh i can't wait to see her should we bring her over no yes blah blah blah should we put should we do this should we do that and just trying to decide and essentially at the six month mark we were like we're not going to stay over two years so we're not going to bring her over and also the discussion of like do we like it here? Do we see a future here? And the answer is no. And the answer is no because of a combination of things. The first is, you know what? The first is that it's just not our city. And I saw this post the other day from this girl who was like every person, I can't remember, it was like, everyone feels like spiritually aligned with like one of these three cities. Like, are you a New York
girl? Are you a Paris girl? Are you a London girl? And there were all these people in the comments being like, I feel like London spiritually in my body. I feel it in my bones. And I just don't feel that. And I have friends who feel that who are like, I love this city. And I'm really giving it a good go. I am going out.
I am doing stuff. I have seen so many West End plays. I don't want to see another musical. Can I be real? I don't really like musical theater that much. And I feel like every Friday night, if I don't have plants, I have to go and see something on the West End. And I'm like, I actually don't like this.
And I just think it's like what the city has to offer is not what we enjoy, which is outdoor spaces, beaches, a bit more convenience, yeah, access to nature, better good weather. And just the culture. Like I just think it's not a fit. So as I said at the beginning of this episode, I'm finding myself in this period of like, okay, cool. Time to wrap it up now. Like, oh, my God, I'm already making, I'm like making plans for the future. I'm like saying to Tom and my friends like, oh yeah, when we go back, like, we're going to get this land and we're going to do this and I'm going to fulfill this dream. And I have had to kind of pull it back a little bit and just as I said, enjoy it.
Like this is not going to last forever. We now know very conclusively we are not relocating here permanently. This, we're having fun at this point. We're enjoying ourselves, but this is not our place. and so now I'm at this point of like, but you can't just be ready to leave at all times. Like mentally you still need to be checked into this experience because this experience isn't going to last.
And at some point I know I'm going to go home to Australia, move somewhere else and really miss our time here and miss our apartment and miss our friends and miss our routines and miss what London does have to offer, which is so much. but yeah that's kind of the where am I going with this that's kind of the conundrum that I'm finding myself in which is like enjoy this now and make the most of this experience rather than idealizing the future the same way that you idealize this future and some of the ways we're really trying to like make the most of this time is um just traveling as much as possible and doing a lot of stuff that like you can only do when you live on this side of the equator so
if you follow me on Instagram, I honestly feel like I need to apologize by how much I post me being like, I'm in Italy, I'm in Vienna, I'm in, I don't know where else I'm going, I'm in Wales, I'm in the Netherlands. I honestly feel like it's kind of aggressive at times to be like, oh my God, look at me traveling all the time, blah, blah, blah. But that's just a bit of like the tall poppy syndrome in me, I think. But yeah, that's what we've said. We've like, okay, if we're going to leave by June next year, we need to just go. And, you know, we need to just go. go ham on the travel plans. And that's what we've done. We've been like, we need to take advantage of this. We need to take advantage of all that London has to offer. And so we've also kind of
been like, I think the mentality I got in was like, we're going to be back and we're going to execute this next part of our life plan, which is to kind of settle down and to really like build a home and like fulfill a longstanding childhood dream. And mentally I was being a little bit like financially cautious because of that because I was like this is a big financial dream I have for the next five to ten years so I really want to save and Tom was like okay but also this is a situation you're never going to get back we're never going to be able to get this visa again we're probably never going to live on the side of the equator again we need to be yes we can be cautious with our money but also we need to be willing to spend it on experiences and we need to be willing to
do the things that we can only do here so we're traveling a lot I've also been better at not complaining about London. I feel like if you're my friend or like a family member, sometimes I can be a little bit annoying with it. Especially with this heat wave, I've been like, I hate it here. I never want to, I don't want, why do we move here? I'm being very cranky and I'm trying to,
I understand I think better than anyone, not better than anyone. I just understand that the thoughts that you have prime, how you experience reality. And so when we were in the middle of winter and especially like when it was freezing cold, we just complained so much. And then obviously we'd go outside and every expectation we had was being met by experiences because we were searching for those bad experiences. We were searching for reasons not to like London. And now I'm like, no, I'm going to give London the benefit of the doubt.
I want it to exceed my expectations. Everything she wants to offer me, I'm going to take with open arms. I'm not going to complain about it. I'm just going to. enjoy it and love this experience. So to kind of wrap up this bonus episode, would I recommend moving to London? What are my future plans kind of looking like? I would recommend moving to London. As much as we've made the decision, and obviously I'm preemptively being like, I'm ready to go, get me out of here. It is an amazing experience. It is incredibly expensive. You will not save any
money while living here. I'm just going to say that. It is incredibly inconvenient at times, but is it worth it? Yes. The experiences that like we have had and I have had, literally last week I was talking on like, I did like a live podcast with my friend Grace on like the second tallest building in London. So one of the tallest buildings in the world and I was like, this is an experience I'm not going to have in Sydney. And that I was just like, that is amazing. I also, guys, I live really close to Tom Hiddleston. I actually know where he lives. He lives, I'm not going to say, I want to say it.
But I know where he lives, because he lives near us. He's like our neighbor. And I see him all the time. I see Paul Meskel all the time, which I feel like everybody in London has the local celebrity that they see. And as much as like I try not to be like consumed by like celebrity culture, it's cool. It's cool to be like, hey. like there's tom hiddleston like hey dude like there he is um like we're friends but like that's that's a really it's like a really cool thing i love going to like richmond park i love going to like the heath
actually i haven't been in a while maybe i'll go this week i love the galleries i love the music opportunities i love how many people we're interviewing for the podcast that like of course i'm not going to interview them they're not going to fly to australia for it um and they're this thing about London where it can be a random Wednesday and suddenly you're like in Hackney and you're like in somebody on somebody's rooftop and like somebody's DJing and there's like and you've just made your new best friend like there's something about this environment that does just breed opportunity and good luck in many many ways so it's taught me a lot it's yeah it really has It's taught me a lot in the way that the best lessons do where they teach you the worst parts of yourself and the best parts of yourself.
And it's definitely taught me some of the worst parts of myself and some of the parts of me that I need to examine a little bit more. But it's also taught me how to just enjoy the moment a little bit more, how to chill out and how to say yes to more things. If you remember the episode I made when I was like, I'm moving to London, these are my expectations, this is what I want. what I said was like oh it's been difficult in the final six months of Sydney because I haven't been you know what's the point in going out because I know I'm leaving soon what's the point in getting a better co-working space because I know I'm leaving soon what's the point in upgrading or updating these things in London I just say yes to everything and that has created a busier life that I was really craving so if you are thinking about it whether or not it is your city whether or not you find that it is the place
you have a spiritual allegiance to or whatnot, it is still worth it for the memories that you will make and for what you will learn. So what are my plans before we leave? So many things. We are doing a summer party in early August for the Psychology of your 20s in London, which is going to be so much fun. We have been just securing so many UK and Europe-based guests to come on the podcast. which I'm so glad for and I am just traveling a shit ton a shit ton and I'm trying well I'm going to
try and do a bunch of different events in different cities so like in Copenhagen I'm going to do one we're doing one in Germany I don't know which city yet we're doing one in France we're doing one in the Netherlands oh did I already say that no in the Netherlands um and so those are kind of our plans and then sneaky on the side, I kind of want to, this is, oh my God, I can't believe maybe mention this. I forgot to mention this. I do have it in my mind that I want to move to New York for three months before we move back to Australia. Because once we move back to Australia, and isn't this the irony of like, tell God your plans and watch him laugh in your face? And I'm sure, I don't know if this will happen or not. And watch me come back on in six months and be like,
hey guys, no, we're like moving to, we're moving to Manchester and we're staying here for 10 years, like completely changing my mind but um i'm really keen to move to new york for three months once we move back to australia i think we're we're settling you know what i mean where it's i think we'll be kind of in that by the time we move back i'll be almost in my 30s what the fuck almost in my 30s and wow and um anyways oh my god realizations and yeah just ready to kind of like pursue a different chapter of life so gonna suck this fruit all the nectar from it that I can right now and that is my London update and that is my grand philosophy to be in the season that you are in as hard as I am finding it it is a guiding thing for me right now that I'm going to
keep coming back to as my touchstone being the season I'm in being the season I'm in appreciate the moment appreciate what you're going to miss about it that is what I keep coming back to and I hope that if you, you know what, I hope that if you've moved somewhere and been like, I actually really don't like it, this makes you realize it's a pretty common experience. I hope you also realize from this episode, it's okay to say, I actually change my mind and I don't like this anymore and I don't want to do this anymore. But I also hope that you've learned to like appreciate the moment for what it is. And if you are somebody who like me at times can be kind of pessimistic and when you have high expectations for things, you know,
I think sometimes it's very easy to be disappointed all the time because you expect big things from yourself. You expect big things from your experiences and sometimes it is about saying I'm just going to accept whatever happens. And I'm going to have no positive, negative, neutral, nothing, no feelings towards this except just a state of acceptance and just openness. And I feel like hopefully this episode has, I don't know, I don't want to say inspired you, but I don't even know how to say this, but just made you realize that other. people struggle with that and that we should keep our minds more open. So there you go. Thank you for listening to this episode. I know I said it was going to be a short bonus episode. I have been speaking for half an hour. If you have made it this far, what should I do in London for my last, you know what is crazy is I'm like, oh, we're leaving in June. It's still a year. I still have a year here,
less, we're probably going to leave in like April. But what should I do? I'm not going to be here forever. I've got less than a year. What are some London bucket list items? If you don't live in London, what are some things that you want, that if you travel to London, you would want to do, that you have done,
that have been on your bucket list, I want to do those. Send them my way. Leave a comment down below. I appreciate it if you've listened this far. Again, you can follow us on Instagram. You can watch full episodes on Netflix. If you didn't already know that,
please go and watch one. It really helps us, like, significantly, if I'm being honest. follow us on Substack, email me. I don't know, you can if you want. Yeah, email me, I guess. But yeah, it's just always, I was going to say, it's just great to talk to you. It's like I'm getting off a long phone call with my friends.
Where you guys have said nothing. But no, it is. It's nice to do episodes like this. So thank you for listening. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101.
It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS. Hey, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast, Here's the Thing.
I talk to composer Mark Shaman. It's about the hang. It's the pleasure of hanging out with the people that you're with. You know, Rob and I was always a great hang. And director Morgan Neville. Film School teaches you all the wrong things about making documentary. What do you want to say? Documentary is all about your ear.
What do you hear? I feel like my job is listening really, really hard. Listen to Here's the Thing on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It just came out. Jeremy, what did you just do? You just sit yourself up for failure. I've never heard you tell this story.
I have never told this story. This must have been tucked deep, deep in the Jeremy Lin file. My name is MC Jen. I'm excited to tell you about laugh but not least. I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times. These will be conversations that remind us all, life is hard. Laugh harder.
Listen to laugh but not least with MCJN on the IHeart Radio app, podcast or wherever you get your podcast. Happy pride from the Outspoken Podcast Network. All month long and all year round, we're celebrating being loud, proud, and always original. It's me, Brandon Kyle Goodman, host of the podcast, Tell Me Something Messy. Check out my show for unfiltered takes on dating, relationships, and adulting. Listen to High Key for the best pop culture takes, and there are no girls on the internet
for all your tech news. For your favorite celebrity key keys, check outlaws with T.S. Madison. Learn to love yourself unapologetically with BFF, Black Fat Fem, and start your day with intention with waking up with Ryan coming in July. Celebrate Pride with the Outspoken Network. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Pride and listen now. This Black Music Month, the Questlove show celebrates the visionaries,
shaping culture, through sound. From country trailblazer Mickey Gaiden to hip-hop icon Fat 5 Freddie, the sonic genius of Thundercat, and the revolutionary voice of Chuck D. I want it loud. So the timing might be off, the sound might be muffled, but what's going to come out of there is something that you can feel. Celebrate Black Music Month with special episodes of The Questlove Show.
Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.